hey guys I'm currently in New York for
the creator summit and I always love
this event because it's an opportunity
for me to talk to a bunch of other
creators that I don't normally get to
talk to and I think a common theme
during this one is that we're all
starting to realize that we're human I
mean it's a it's common knowledge that
youtubers try to compete to see who can
be the most hardworking person out there
but but I always enjoy taking the time
to talk with people personally not about
YouTube not about how how the numbers
are doing but how they're doing in their
life and like I said one of the common
themes is that we all have points where
our creativity breaks down a bit we all
have points so self-doubt and we all
have points of just where we're feeling
low in life so I wanted to make a video
to kind of convey some knowledge because
I'm actually doing I'm actually doing
really well right now I'm in a good
place in my life I feel I feel fulfilled
creatively and I feel like I'm on the
path to doing something more and that
that's owed largely in part to the fact
that I'm not taking everything so
seriously as I used to I'm trying to be
more like myself I'm trying to be more
open about my feelings but I also wanted
to make a video that you guys could
watch if you're ever feeling low and
you're ever feeling like the world is
coming down around you first and
foremost is that it is absolutely okay
to feel down it's absolutely okay to
feel sad you don't have to put up a
front of happiness you don't have to put
up a fake wall of doing fine you can be
real about your emotions you can you can
be honest with yourself and you can be
honest with those around you you don't
have to worry about burdening those
around you with your sadness you don't
have to internalize it always and number
two you have to identify what it really
is that's causing your sadness we've had
a few speakers here at the creator
summit one of them was Erik Barker who
was talking in great length about how
success measures towards happiness and a
lot of it you know isn't a competition
between happiness and success it's it's
about
using those two things in conjunction
with each other now you feeling down
maybe the result of someone bullying you
or the result of you bullying yourself
and one of those things is something
that you can change and one of those
things is something that you can try to
change you know others bullying you is a
problem of the environment that you're
in and the steps to be taken to change
that or harder than one might think but
even harder than that are the steps to
stop bullying yourself
which is the one thing that you
definitely can change but probably the
one thing that we all do more than
anything else so identifying if your
depression or your sadness is coming
from a place of internal hate is
something that plagues a lot of us and
and also it's it's not something that
needs to be fixed right away some some
of us get down on ourselves I can me
myself included because we expect so
much out of ourselves you know we want
to do so much therefore we're upset when
we do less and that's a poisonous way of
thinking and it's a poisonous like a
route to take yourself down because it
only means that you don't celebrate your
successes enough and you only admonish
your failures and that's no way to live
so if you're if you're ever feeling this
way just remember that you you can
choose to forgive yourself for
transgressions you can choose to forgive
yourself for failures you can choose to
be above your own hate and take that as
an example for the hate and the world
around you a lot of bullying these days
are people that are projecting their own
hate on themselves upon others so that
they can escape their pain and you know
that's no way to live but that's someone
else's problems if you're feeling down
about yourself then many times you just
need to forgive yourself but there's
also environmental factors that aren't
you being mad at yourself or being upset
with yourself they're their situational
things money's not enough you know your
home life isn't solid here your your
relationships are breaking down you
don't feel like you have friends to
surround yourself with and in those
times
I don't have an anecdotal piece of
advice or words that are gonna fix your
problem or even likely to make you feel
better but if it does bring you any
solace just know that I really honestly
truly believe that you can get through
it i honest believe that you're strong
enough to pursue your goals and to
conquer your dreams and go farther than
you ever thought possible but the only
way to do it is to keep trying no matter
what no matter what gets in your way no
matter what adversity you face if you
keep trying if you never give up
if you always pursue that thing which
makes you happier the thing that makes
you burn inside you for the the ambition
that you have the projects that you see
on the horizon the dreams that you hope
to achieve if you keep your eye on them
and not just on the dream itself because
if you obsess about the dream and what
it will mean when you get there you'll
ignore all of the obstacles on the path
like really focus on the whole picture
of everything if you're trying to do
something and you're constantly met with
failure or your friends don't believe in
you or your family doesn't believe in
you then those are obstacles that are on
your path to your goal and you need to
see the whole picture you need to
realize that that some dreams carry a
heavy price but if they're worth it then
nothing can stop you and this is
something that's pushed me to where I am
today that's something that's gotten me
where I am because when I started
YouTube or when I started just in
general wanting to take control of my
life I looked at the entire road ahead
of me or as far as I could possibly see
and I was been with more obstacles than
I ever could have imagined but what it
took and what I realized right away was
it took sacrifice and it took Drive and
it took unyielding passion and it took
sleepless nights and it took lost
friends and it took fake friends and it
took my parents not believing in me it
took it took that and and after I pushed
beyond that
I started to gain the recognition that I
was right all along and it's it's not as
simple as that but that's what it boils
down to so if you're feeling low or you
feeling down or you feeling like you're
not succeeding in life or you're feeling
like those around you aren't supporting
you just remember that I believe in you
and that everyone here in the comments
believes in you
and that we're all in the same boat
together and we can all succeed if we
just believe in each other and believe
in ourselves so yeah I gotta get down
we've got more events today thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I'll see you in the next video
bye bye